five all day look at the time right now
yo what's important is he just builds a
live lead right now because it's gonna
be very hard to bring it back kid if
anyone can do it it's a kuma bot with
eight seconds no meter stroke is strong
is just gonna stay down yeah he he can't
lose this round
right sure about that right sure are you
sure okay come on
four i'm liking what i'm saying straight
away back to four um yeah this this is
looking like a strong king already nice
bat one two nice stuck in punish there
from mob we're not going to break the
water oh he's going for the fancy stuff
oh
yay oh but the hot knee
this could be the route no comp no the
balcony that wasn't oh wait would this
work he's going to be airborne oh he did
what
that was a punish three
trying to set something up the king wave
dash
train grab what are we going for oh no
no no no no no no no he gets him we're
going round and round guys this is going
to be great for him as well
what's the okay could jump over
no oh very very nice nice
again oh greetings two
small folks right now for that oh that
could have been up last attempt there
were no strokes on point with it today
oh
this is what i mean it's a mirror match
down back four at the same time but
mobile just slightly faster
nice place
and mob is gonna draw first blood
one
okay the racetrack gets the flow loads
him yeah that wasn't the best situation
though not broken though enrage
mob can take this running explode off
nine seconds left
can greetings steal this one
five seconds the while two is getting
back
two seconds down back through the
orbital back that's gonna wait here this
time
[Music]
[Music]
you